the parents of the 19 year old Penn
State student who died at a fraternity
house are channeling their grief into a
call for action
Timothy Piazza died in February after an
alleged hazing ritual at the Beta Theta
Pi frat house a grand jury report
details how surveillance cameras inside
captured the events leading to his death
18 fraternity members face charges they
are expected to appear in court later
this week
Jericka Duncan spoke with the Piazza
family and Timothy's girlfriend Rika
good morning good morning Nora Timothy
Piazza's family has not seen the video
that according to the grand jury report
shows fraternity members carrying
Piazza's limp body upstairs smacking him
in the face and pouring liquid on him as
he goes in and out of consciousness for
hours this wasn't boys being boys this
was murder of our son they tortured him
for 12 hours they let him suffer for 12
hours he died a slow and painful death
at the hands of these men of principle
as they call it Jim and Evelyn Piazza
their son Mike and Timothy Piazza's
girlfriend Kaitlyn Tim Polsky are
struggling to make sense of how Timothy
died to hit him and slap him and
brutalize him they should not have been
trying to get a response they should
have been trying to get him help how do
you pour liquid on someone slap them in
the face and hit them after you just
watched them fall and they were
unconscious according to this grand jury
report Beta Theta Pi pledges were forced
to consume heavy amounts of alcohol in a
short amount of time as part of a hazing
ritual within three hours
prosecutors say 19 year-old Piazza fell
down a flight of basement stairs didn't
know that he was laying at the bottom of
the basement steps for any length of
time all by himself
it almost terrible the president of the
university said that Beta Theta Pi will
never return to Penn State University
does that give you some solace No first
of all we told them that had to happen
that's not enough what are the top three
changes you would want to see in the
next six months to a year they need to
eliminate alcohol provided to minors
they need to come down very hard in any
situations where there's hazing and I
think fraternities and sororities maybe
need an adult chaperone
all the time 18 members of Beta Theta Pi
have been charged in connection to
Piazza's death 8 face felony charges
that could result in up to 20 years in
prison I have a lifetime of absence for
my son I would be good with 20 years
what would you say to those students as
they're entering colleges they're
thinking about joining a fraternity or
sorority if anybody tries to make you do
something that's the illegal don't do it
walk away walk away you don't want to be
brothers with those guys do you wish you
would have had that conversation with
your son
we did have some of those conversations
I think the alcohol came fast and
furious and he didn't know you know I
just think it just got away you got
carried away what do you want people to
remember about Timothy about your son
about your brother about your boyfriend
he could always put a smile on
everyone's face he's such a good heart
kind funny he was just an awesome
individual and were a little worse off
as a world without a minute the
fraternity's national organization
disbanded the chapter saying it does not
tolerate hazing or alcohol abuse in any
form that's a sentiment echoed by the
university president since the release
of the grand jury report the university
launched its own investigation the
president of the university says that
could very well lead to expulsion I mean
this family said this isn't just their
son
this was everyone's son because they
feel this could have happened I know I
look at that picture and I think anybody
with a child can relate to that and as
painful as it is
listen it's painful to Rika just to
watch them I can't imagine what it's
like for them to have the feelings that
they have but I'm so glad that they're
speaking out because this is such a
stupid stupid thing yeah enough
happening that their son is dead to me
any facts in dispute about this you know
the defense has not really come out we
heard from some of the attorneys
representing the 18 that have been
charged but they're still you know a lot
to be seen the the preliminary hearing
scheduled for this week we might see
some of that surveillance video that was
in that house and if not for that
surveillance video we probably wouldn't
even be here talking about it I know you
spoke with him for a long time what did
you find out about the outpouring of
support they've received the the mother
and father sat down with me and showed
me numerous cards hundreds of cards that
they received from around the world and
really letting them know that they want
these parents to be an agent of change
they want to make sure that students
recognize the severity involved because
you know we've all been there and like
their parents said this really could
have been anyone's anyone's child it
didn't have to happen nobody called 911
it's it's so sad but I'm very glad you
did that story
thanks I read to the family for speaking
to us